schnee ist liegt der duft in der luft
der jedem wurde kann
wenn die weihnachtsfeierlichkeiten
verliebt in der weihnachtszeit sehr lieb
vekselberg
die bank wird sony die trocken green
bank zusammen mit dominik ein tierisches
meisterwerk und jetzt kommt ihr das
spannend teil wir müssen jetzt in der
mitte sondern holt auch schaffner
fahnder nämlich die bonbons raus
eine bunte kerzen torte für dominik
schwester inklusive überraschung da muss
jetzt richtiges werkzeug 15 uhr hallo
herzlich willkommen so salis welt das
war ziemlich hoch gerdes wir haben jetzt
gerade die scheibe eingeschlagen
egal das kriegen wir egal macht nichts
das ich so jetzt lasse ich so weiter
gibt eine torte und so eine
weihnachtskarte ja mal wieder eine torte
aber ich hatte schon lange nicht mehr
glaube ich so normale torten weit und
ich habe heute auf instagram so kurz war
knapp eine abstimmung gemacht möchte die
eine torte mit fondue oder möchte dir
lieber eine torte oder von dort und die
abstimmung die war hatte ich zeige euch
hier
wir haben 21 tausend stimmen ohne von
rund 8700 stimmen mit von dort das heißt
die von dort hat gewonnen
die ohne von kartoffel das ist okay für
manche menschen sind ja aus als wir also
nicht fertig der kuchen aber ob das
wirklich das dauern heißt auch negativ
das ist ne kitkat das heißt man kann von
außen gut hinein sehen und sieht was in
der torte eben sich abspielt und zwar
habe ich jetzt ein paar weil winter
klassiker in dieser torte vereint und
zwar einmal gebrannte mandeln die habe
ich jetzt selbst gemacht da gibt es auch
schon ein rezept auf einem kanal
aber ich zeige es euch auch gleich noch
mal manchmal eine probieren habe meine
chance ihr nein
diesem folgt dann habe ich eine vanille
creme vanillekipferl creme und jahrzehnt
haben wir da schon mit dabei also so ein
bisserl weihnachtsklassiker alles in
einem verbunden und das ganze mit einer
pflaume und frucht ein lager so dass das
wirklich eine schöne fruchtige torte
wird hier oben das ist das schöne an der
torte also nicht nur das ist eine torte
isst sondern auch die deko das sind
diese tannenbäume auf modelle schokolade
die sind super einfach in der
herstellung und vor allem könnt ihr sie
auch schon eine woche vorher herstellen
und dann habt ihr nächster woche nämlich
keinen stress zu wenig genau
und für alle die wie ich die hauptschule
siebten klasse abgebrochen haben michael
keck heißt nakba kuhn genau man back den
nicht nackt sondern der kuchen schmeckt
so zu sagen weil ich noch mal
klarstellen ich zeige jetzt zuerst
einmal wie man die gebrannten mandeln
herstellt die sollten mich schon mal
haben denn die kommen in den teig also
hier die zutaten für die gebrannten
mandeln für die gebrannten mandeln
brauch ich 200 gramm ganze mandeln 100
milliliter wasser 100 gramm zucker und
die habe ich noch gewürze einen
teelöffel zimt eine tonkabohne einen
teelöffel extrakt und eine prise salz
zuerst kommt jetzt das wasser in eine
pfanne
da kommt der zucker dazu und auch gleich
die gewürze also ziemlich dem noch ein
bisschen tonkabohne tonkabohne gesagt
verfeinert mit vanille extrakt und eine
prise salz und jetzt dürfen die zutaten
einmal kurz aufkochen
sobald die zutaten kochen kommen jetzt
die mandeln dazu jetzt lass ich das
ganze so lange kochen bis die
flüssigkeit weg ist dann werden die
mandeln ganz trocken und der zucker wird
trocken und danach karamellisiert alles
hier zieht man die flüssigkeit ist fast
weg das heißt ich schalte zum härten ein
bisschen runter und jetzt muss aber die
flüssigkeit noch mal komplett verdampfen
jetzt wird's gleich trocken und danach
karamellisierter zucker erst und jetzt
müssen richtig aufpassen dass der zucker
nicht verbrennt druck weil jetzt kommt
der funk ist in jeder partie sind kaputt
aber nein sie sind nicht kaputt sie
müssen wir zweiter gerührt werden jetzt
jeder zucker trocken und dann
karamellisierte ihr habt nichts falsch
gemacht ihr müsst einfach weitermachen
es sollte motivationstrainer werden für
gebrannte mandeln er weiter
[Musik]
gib nicht auf
wir könnten jetzt müssen die
karamellisieren
geschafft
blaue wand
jetzt sind sie trocken
wenn ich das schaffe schaffst du das
auch
jetzt sind es schön karamellisiert und
glänzen wieder
jetzt kann ich hier auch eine back folie
ein bisschen back trance trail geben
ihr könnt doch einfach ein backblech
nehmen und das einfetten mit bisschen öl
da kommen jetzt die gebrannten mandeln
drauf und dann kann ich sehr verteilt
und musste jetzt abkühlen lassen also
nicht mit den fingern dran und nicht
probieren nicht naschen sondern erst mal
komplett abkühlen lassen und das jetzt
nicht so arg zusammenkleben sie's jetzt
während dem abkühlen so ein bisschen
auseinander
die mandeln sind jetzt abgekühlt ich
zeig euch jetzt die zutaten für den teig
für den teig brauche ich vier eier 200
gramm zucker eine prise salz und etwas
vanille extrakt jeweils 200 milliliter
sonnenblumenöl und mineralwasser 265
gramm mehl 1 3 viertel teelöffel
backpulver 120 gramm gemahlene mandeln
und 150 gramm gebrannte mandeln jetzt
gebe ich zuerst einmal die eier innere
schüssel
da kommt der zucker dazu und genauso
salz und vanille extrakt und dann werden
die zutaten für etwa zehn minuten ganz
cremig verrührt und in der zwischenzeit
kann ich schon mal die gebrannten
mandeln so ein bisschen hacken
[Musik]
wenn die masse dann cremig jetzt kommen
noch die flüssigkeit mit dazu und werden
kurz eingerührt
[Musik]
jetzt kuriere ich kurz das backpulver
mit dem mehl und gebt die trockenen
zutaten dazu und die werden auch kurz
ein gehört gemeinsam mit den gehackten
mandeln
[Musik]
das wird ein richtig schöner kranjec und
denen fühle ich jetzt in zwei bringe die
habe ich bereits auf 20 zentimeter
eingestellt
und so kommt der thai gibt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 35 minuten
und die zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt um
die deko vorzubereiten
die torte möchte ich jetzt diese
tannenbäume herstellen und die sehen
wirklich super hübsch aus wenn man sie
später ein stich in die torte und dafür
nehme ich jetzt modelle schokolade weil
die zum einen gut schmeckt sie hat 25
echter schokolade mit dabei und zum
anderen geht es halt super einfach ich
habe hier ein bisschen grün wird aber
auch noch ein paar farbabweichungen
machen mit weiß und blau so ein bisschen
was mission
jetzt könnt ihr das ganze war kneten und
einen langen dünnen strang formen
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich den tannenbaum so im
zickzack form hinlegen und damit ich
immer eine schöne form habe habe ich
hier einfach im dreieck ausgeschnitten
das kann auf papier seien oder aus
karton und da kann ich sitz drauflegen
[Musik]
bei bedarf könnt ihr die strenge auch
ein bisschen zusammenleben aber die
modelle schokolade diva jetzt schön warm
durch die hand wärme und es klebt auch
so ganz gut zusammen nämlich so
vorsichtig hoch und nehme jetzt hier
einen schaschlikspieß da kommt ein
bisschen essbarer kleber darauf lege ich
den spieß direkt rüber auf die unterlage
wo ich es eben trocknen lassen und kann
dem baum vorsichtig ankleben und dann so
trocknen lassen
[Musik]
und wer möchte kann sie jetzt noch mit
essbaren zuckerperlen bekleben
[Musik]
die tannenbäume wir dürfen jetzt
trocknen ich stelle jetzt eine frucht
einlage her und ich finde dass pflaumen
ganz gut in die torte reinpassen
also habe ich hier flammen aus dem glas
mit der flüssigkeit das sind etwa 540
gramm zehn gramm agata und ich habe noch
den abrieb von der bio zitrone und die
pflaumen pury ich jetzt einfach kurz mit
dem st
jetzt kommt das fruchtpüree in einen
topf gemeinsam mit dem acker und im
zitronen abrieb und dann lasse ich die
macher jetzt aufkochen und zwei minuten
sprudelnd kochen damit das agora wirken
kann
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die masse in torten ringe
ein film die sind im durchmesser 18 cm
groß und dann kann ich sie gleich eins
drin und habe dann zwei frucht einlagen
[Musik]
die tortenböden sind gebacken und ich
hatte es jetzt auch schon im kühlschrank
das sehr schön kalt sind und ich sie
gleich schneiden kann die frucht anlage
ist eingefroren die tannenbäume sind
vorbereitet also folgt jetzt noch die
creme da machen wir eine vanillecreme
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für die
creme brauchen dich 600 milliliter
schlagsahne 500 gramm magerquark 300 g
frischkäse in doppel ram stufe etwas
vanille extrakt ein päckchen sonderfahrt
und 100 gramm puderzucker zuerst nehme
ich jetzt die sahne
die kommt in der rührschüssel und ich
brauche jetzt einfach pro 100 gramm asse
einen teelöffel seiner fahrt zum fest
werden
das heißt ich kann jetzt die sahen ein
bisschen anrühren und dann hier schon
mal sechs teelöffel dazu geben
[Musik]
während die sahne steif schlagen kann
ich schon mal gesagt dass strehse hier
verrühren
hier kommt jetzt noch die vanille rein
puderzucker und dann ab
die dadurch jetzt fast steif da kommt
jetzt die creme dazu und dann kann ich
sie ganz vorsichtig steif schlagen
[Musik]
die creme ist es schön fest und ich habe
sie in einen spritzbeutel rein gefüllt
so gar nicht die torte gleich besser
befüllen die böden sind wie gesagt schön
kalt und die schneide ich jetzt einmal
durch so dass ich vier dünne böden habe
mit stapel ich die torte auch direkt auf
meiner schönen tortenplatte
[Musik]
da sieht man es auch schön den mandeln
jetzt mache ich hier eine spitze weg und
kam schon mal den boden damit bestritten
also den tortenboden nicht den boden das
mache ich auch oft aber heute nicht
[Musik]
jetzt die frucht einlage lösen dies
jetzt auch gefroren bekommt jetzt hier
rein
nochmal eine schicht von der creme und
so stapel ich dann die gesamte torte
[Musik]
in die mitte kommen jetzt noch mal
gebrannte mandeln und in die obere
schicht kommt nochmal die frucht 1 lag
[Musik]
jetzt ist die torte gestartet bei mir
ist es eine ziemlich hohe torte wenn ihr
sie gerne etwas flacher haben möchtet
könnt ihr einfach den durchmesser der
backformen ein bisschen vergrößern und
hat dann eine grössere aber flache
retorte ich finde aber hoch immer ganz
schön und so kommt sie jetzt erst mal in
den kühlschrank für etwa zwei stunden
und dann können wir sie noch dekoriert
und dann anrichten
das schon dass ich mal ein hochstapler
oder jetzt ist die torte gut gekühlt und
wenn ihr möchtet könnt jetzt noch ein
paar kokosraspeln nehmen um auf der
oberfläche her sondern keine schnee
struktur zu machen wenn ihr die aber
geschmacklich nicht nur glas einfach weg
ich finde es richtig hübsch und vor
allem sehr lecker
und jetzt kann ich die tannenbäume
reinstecken
[Musik]
wo sie die torte jetzt aus und der murat
steht schon in den startlöchern um zu
probieren
[Musik]
bereits jetzt ist halt echt eine hohe
torte also ich muss sagen mir gefällt
jetzt für die fotos ganz gut aber wenn
ich jetzt noch mal backe dann mache ich
ein bisschen flacher und durchmisst
einfach größer dann ist halt ein
bisschen handlicher und es hat nicht
jeder so ein mega monströses kuchenstück
oder des bildes das ja das sieht dann
frau kohl auf interesse von auf unserem
blog bereit gibt es nur einen teller hat
ein teller
macht den teller hoch kam schnell
doch so wie gerade eben glück okay du
musst aber das stück jetzt bitte nicht
alleine essen okay ja so also ist es ein
riesen stück aber dem gestühl weise hoch
ist wie gesagt macht ein bisschen
flacher ein bisschen breiter und oliver
abgekühlt
ja weil schon jetzt gemerkt hat woran
würde den finger drin hatte ich nicht
mehr heiß und und eine frucht einlage in
der mitte die mandeln oben wieder fort
anlage und dem mantel natürlich noch im
teig und crunchy was meint so muss an
den weihnachtlichen so muss echt sein
wie meine haltung kenne jetzt auch
schneeregen mal richtig mit mit mandel
mitsingen schmeckt richtig weihnachten
und vor allem nicht so schwer oder und
von der vorbereitung her echt super ihr
könnt die bäume schon herstellen ihr
könnt die frucht einlage schon
herstellen im prinzip könnt ihr auch
wenn ihr möchtet schon die böden vor
backen und einfrieren also
aufgeschnitten einfrieren und dann habt
ihr am weihnachtstag oder am tag vorher
gar keinen stress mehr und habe eine
richtig schöne und vor allem sehr
leckere weihnachtskarten können schmoll
kurz drauf ich kann dann muss zeigen
kannst du mal der boden sieht lustig aus
mit den mantel siehst du das mal hier
hier sind die mandeln bringen die blüten
die mangel drin und die früchte einlage
auch richtig schön fest richtig cool
zuliebe frucht einnahmen gut oder komm
jetzt lasse noch ein bisschen was übrig
dann essen wir das stück zusammen nein
ich hab gewusst dass etwas sagt dann
lässt sich das stück war knapp und
dudelsack ja okay okay gut auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt kam übrigens der kuchen
auch sehr gut an bei den zuschauern
wir waren ja auf dem stuttgarter
weihnachtsmarkt da kam der kuchen auch
richtig gut an
also fand ihr das rezept auch gerne
nachmachen möchte dann schaut auf meinem
blog vorbei aufs ellis blog.de da steht
noch mal alles ganz genau
wir wünschen euch schon mal eine richtig
schöne weihnachtszeit lange ist es ja
nicht mehr genau
und bis dahin kommen noch zwei rezepte
online und ja alles alles gute und bis
zum nächsten mal
und wer fragt warum es nicht mehr so
weihnachtlich geschmückt ist
es soll auch ein kuss war ein fauxpas
von uns wir haben nämlich zwischendurch
noch ein video für januar gefilmt und
dann haben halt ab dekoriert ja heute
erst wieder aufzulegen wieder zu decken
auf jeden fall
trotzdem wir sind wie weihnachten und
soli machen die torben queen bank
zusammen mit dominik ein tierisches
meisterwerk und jetzt kommt ihr das
spannend teil du bist jetzt in der mitte
sondern eine bunte katzen torte für
dominik schwester inklusive überraschung
dar selbst richtiges wechselt
sally bott so 15 uhr
[Musik]